[Music]
there's not a face for every culture
every ethnicity every
race
so when you tell me that i'm too dark to
be dominican
show me what a dominican looks like
and then try to tell me that i'm not
dominican enough
because you're wrong i'm dominican i'm
black i'm an afro latina and you can't
tell me any different
[Music]
an afro-latina is simply
a person who just identifies with their
blackness
that's it i'm a black girl and my family
is from dominican republic but people
say i'm too dark to be dominican
people say i can't be latina growing up
there was no one who looked like me i
remember just being called charcoal i
remember being called too dirty at one
point i stopped saying i was dominican
my goal is simply to be able to help the
youth feel comfortable in their skin and
own it
most people know me as monica style muse
over on youtube instagram you name it
i've been able to be extremely
successful as an afro-latina in the
beauty space this is one of my favorite
eyebrow pencils because the precision
just makes your brows you know i live
for a brow lift i'm not the best makeup
artist and never did i ever say i was
but i feel like if i can at least just
inspire
other people to just live in their own
truth regardless of what other people
think i know her because i follow her on
instagram
oh she likes me i like her
[Music]
it took me maybe three years to really
find myself and to be my own muse on my
channel you can print this all over your
face to really bring the moisture back
into your face so you look refreshed
one day i just decided you know what i'm
going to be myself
at first when i started speaking spanish
on my channel they were like can you
stop this can you just make a separate
channel and i said you know what no this
is who i am and it was the best decision
i've ever made for myself being a latina
means knowing that you have a culture
and a background and a story that can't
also be taken from you my audience is
this sassy
person who is just so ready to take on
whatever the world throws at them
they're gonna figure it out one way or
another and that's what i've done
even like thinking back to little monica
baby monica was so timid she was so
scared of the world i'm an adult now you
can't really faze me cause
which means if my shine bothers you
that's not my problem
[Music]
you're in mississippi
and everywhere you go tamales
those magical little snacks of corn
flour and meat
packed into a corn husk tamales tamales
tamales
so if you've ever wondered what
mississippi tastes like
it tastes like me
the tamale
[Music]
my journey starts almost 100 years ago
it's 1930
and mexican migrants are trickling into
mississippi
they bring along a taste of home
their version of the sandwich
me
the tamale
my great grandfather came here from
mexico city
jumped the trains ended up in
mississippi he decided to make his
family's homemade hand-rolled hot
tamales and in 1939 opened up this place
and started selling tamales
you have to understand this is a family
thing i'm the fourth generation
these same generational people who've
been coming to the big apple in for the
last 78 years are also generational
when they eat a tamale they always have
a story my daddy used to bring me here
his daddy had the same kind of story his
daddy had the same kind of story
tamales caught on here and it became a a
staple in in the city
so there i am winning over the
mississippi natives and as i make my way
up into the delta
my location may change but little did i
know that the tradition of family
most certainly would not
just like gino and his grandfather at
the big apple inn i bring the scott
family together a family who has gone on
to be known
as the first family of tamales in
mississippi
in the early 50s my father bought the
recipe from a mexican guy
my mother and father taught me
my sisters and my niece all of us
together we're making hot tamales we
just one big hot tamale family
any business that's family oriented i
think it'll last longer
[Music]
much like the scott family
the doe family is made up of a long line
of tamale makers
doze eat place is a landmark restaurant
that helped propel me to become the
backbone of mississippi cuisine i've
become today
[Music]
my daddy started this restaurant in
1941 with my mother we've been here 76
years
mama had a
sister that was living here
and daddy had a couple of two or three
sisters that were living here so they
all came and rolled tamales
you know a lot of people ask ask us you
know how did tamales get prevalent in
the delta
it's been family you know the family's
been here all the time
as tamales made their way from mexican
culture to african-american communities
and on to mississippi's white population
there's one thing that remained a
constant
family
the most southern concept of all
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
different
than most mariachis
we're formed in new york city we're all
women
most people think of mariachis being
from mexico as being men as being macho
and
you know
we're pretty much opposite of all those
things
i started my musical career playing with
a local omelet mariachi in brooklyn
for me it was really hard to communicate
with other male mariachis because of the
machismo that's very vivid and in the
culture and in the genre of mariachi
that's kind of why i i wanted to start
my own group
and that led
for me to do a all-female group because
i didn't want to deal with men
it is not so much that people say you're
not a mariachi but it's the
the fact that they think that we cannot
play mariachi because we're women and
we're wearing pants and we have curly
hair and and we don't look mexican or
we don't have this look that they're
expecting
[Music]
as a women mariachi we're technically
supposed to be wearing skirts
and
didn't work for us
it's one of the most passionate music
that i've ever heard it's just beautiful
it's
very heartfelt and
i think that's what makes mariachi so
special
it's my dream to be able to perform and
and connect with people through music
i don't think i could ask for more you
know and that's what keeps us going i
think
thank you so much gracias
thank you so much everybody we love you
[Music]
this is what a typical bodega sounds
like
but this bodega sounds a little
different
[Music]
almost every street corner in new york
city has a small store with sandwiches
groceries and drinks
this is a bodega
yo
one second
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
you